y por lo tanto a la sociedad,
en el rango de USD 380 000 millones al año.
Todos podemos recordar algunos ejemplos, ¿verdad?
Los secretos de la industria automotriz dejaron de ser secretos.
El fraude pasó a ser una característica,
no un error,
de la industria de servicios financieros.
No estoy yo declarando esto,
sino el presidente de la Asociación Financiera Estadounidense,
que declaró esto en su discurso presidencial.
Eso es un gran problema, si pensamos, especialmente,
en una economía como Suiza,
que se basa en la confianza puesta en su industria financiera.
Por otra parte,
hay un grupo de seis o siete compañías que permanecen honestas
más allá de las tentaciones de comenzar a participar en el fraude.
Hay denunciantes, como Michael Woodford,
quien denunció a Olympus.
Estos denunciantes arriesgan sus carreras,
sus amistades,
para exponer la verdad acerca de sus compañías.
Hay periodistas, como Anna Politkovskaya,
que hasta arriesgan sus vidas para reportar violaciones de derechos humanos.
Ella fue muerta...
cada año,
mueren unos 100 periodistas,
por su convicción en descubrir la verdad.
Así que en mi charla hoy,
deseo compartir con Uds. algunos conocimientos que obtuve y aprendí
investigando esto en los últimos diez años.
Soy investigador, un científico que trabaja con economistas,
economistas financieros,
expertos en ética, neurocientíficos,
abogados y otros,
que intenta comprender qué motiva a los seres humanos,
y cómo podemos encarar este asunto de fraude en corporaciones,
y contribuir de esa manera a mejorar el mundo.
Deseo compartir dos versiones muy diferentes
de cómo actúan las personas.
Primero, aquí Adam Smith,
padre fundador de la economía moderna.
Su idea básica era que si todos actúan en su propio interés,
eso es bueno para todos al final.
El interés personal no es un concepto estrechamente definido
para su inmediato consumo.
Tiene una implicación a largo plazo.
Elaboremos un poco sobre eso.
Piense en este perro aquí.
Podría ser nosotros.
Existe la tentación...
disculpas a los vegetarianos, pero...
(Risas)
Los perros gustan de las salchichas.
Ahora, el directo interés personal que actúa aquí
es ir a por eso.
Así que mi amigo Adam aquí, podría saltar,
tomar la salchicha y arruinar esta hermosa vajilla.
Pero eso no es lo que Adam Smith quiso significar.
Él no dijo ignore todas las consecuencias,
por el contrario.
Él hubiera pensado,
bien, puede haber consecuencias negativas,
por ejemplo,
el dueño podría enojarse con el perro,
y el perro, anticipándose a eso, podría no actuar así.
Eso podríamos ser nosotros,
sopesando los costos y beneficios de nuestras acciones.
¿Cómo se materializa eso?
Bien, muchos de nosotros, estoy seguro,
tenemos en nuestras compañías,
especialmente en grandes compañías,
un código de conducta.
Y cuando actuamos de manera acorde a ese código,
eso aumenta nuestras posibilidades de obtener un pago extra.
En caso contrario, si lo ignoramos,
existen grandes posibilidades de no obtener el pago extra,
o se verá disminuido.
En otras palabras,
esta es una motivación económica,
intentando que las personas sean más honestas,
o más alineadas con los principios corporativos.
Similarmente, la reputación es otra poderosa fuerza económica, ¿correcto?
Todos intentamos construir una reputación,
quizás la de ser honestos,
porque así las personas confían más en nosotros.
¿Correcto?
Adam Smith habló del panadero,
que no está produciendo buen pan por ser benevolente
con las personas que lo consumen,
sino porque desea vender más pan en el futuro.
En mi investigación encontramos, por ejemplo,
en la Universidad de Zúrich,
que los bancos suizos que resultan expuestos a la prensa,
y en un contexto, por ejemplo,
evasión fiscal, o fraude impositivo,
reciben una mala cobertura de prensa.
Pierden el ingreso de nuevo dinero de cara al futuro
y, por lo tanto, menos beneficios.
Esa es una poderosa fuerza de reputación.
Beneficios y costos.
Aquí otra visión del mundo.
Conozcan a Immanuel Kant,
genial filósofo alemán del siglo XVIII
que desarrolló esta noción,
que independientemente de las consecuencias,
algunas acciones están bien
y otras simplemente mal.
Está mal mentir, por ejemplo,
así que, descubran a mi amigo Immanuel ahora.
Él sabe que la salchicha es muy sabrosa,
pero la va a rechazar porque es un buen perro.
Sabe que está equivocado saltar
y arriesgar arruinar la hermosa vajilla.
Si uno cree que las personas están motivadas así,
entonces, todas estas cosas acerca de los incentivos,
acerca del código de conducta, pagos extras y demás,
carece mayormente de sentido.
Las personas están motivadas por diferentes valores, quizás.
Entonces, ¿qué motiva a las personas?
Estos dos caballeros aquí tienen peinados perfectos,
si bien nos brindan muy diferentes visiones del mundo.
¿Qué hacemos con esto?
Bien, yo soy economista,
y conducimos experimentos para abordar este asunto.
Nos despojamos de los hechos que en realidad son confusos.
La realidad es tan grande, suceden tantas cosas que
es casi imposible saber lo que motiva el comportamiento de las personas.
Así que hagamos un pequeño experimento juntos.
Imaginen el siguiente escenario.
Están solos en su habitación,
no como aquí.
Hay una moneda de cinco francos como la que estoy sosteniendo ahora
frente a usted.
Aquí están sus instrucciones:
arroje la moneda cuatro veces,
y luego, en la computadora frente a usted,
ingrese el número de veces que salió cruz.
Esta es la situación.
Aquí está el problema.
Por cada vez que anuncia que recibió cruz,
obtiene cinco francos.
Así que, si dice haber conseguido dos veces cruz,
obtiene diez francos.
si dice que ninguno, no recibe nada.
Si dice, "conseguí cruz cuatro veces",
entonces recibe 20 francos.
Es anónimo,
nadie observa lo que está haciendo,
y recibe anónimamente el pago.
Tengo dos preguntas para usted.
(Risas)
Uds. conocen lo que viene ahora, ¿verdad?
Primero, ¿cómo se comportarían en esa situación?
Segundo, observen a su izquierda y a su derecha...
(Risas)
y piensen cómo la persona sentada a su lado
se comportaría en esa situación.
Hicimos este experimento en serio.
Lo hicimos en la exhibición de Arte Manifesta
ocurrida en Zúrich recientemente,
no en la universidad, con estudiantes en el laboratorio,
sino con público real,
como ustedes.
Primero, recordemos las estadísticas.
Si arrojo la moneda cuatro veces, y se trata de una moneda imparcial,
entonces la probabilidad de que salga cruz cuatro veces
es 6,25 %.
Y espero que puedan ver intuitivamente,
que la probabilidad de ser cruz de todas ellas es más baja
que si solo dos resultan cruz, ¿correcto?
Aquí están los números específicos.
Esto es lo que sucedió.
Las personas hicieron este experimento en serio.
Cerca del 30 al 35 % de ellas dijo:
"Bien, yo arrojé cruz cuatro veces".
Eso es extremadamente improbable.
(Risas)
Aunque lo realmente asombroso aquí,
quizás para un economista,
es que alrededor del 65 % de las personas no dijeron yo arrojé cruz cuatro veces,
a pesar de que en esa situación,
nadie está vigilando,
la única consecuencia conocida
es que obtiene más dinero si dice cuatro antes que menos.
Deja 20 francos en la mesa anunciando cero.
No sé si acaso las otras personas fueron honestas,
o acaso dijeron un poco más o un poco menos de lo que hicieron
porque es anónimo.
Nosotros solo observamos la distribución.
Aunque lo que puedo decir... y aquí lanzamos otra moneda.
Ahí tienes, son cruces.
(Risas)
No vigilen, ¿sí?
Lo que puedo decirles,
es que nadie se comportó como Adan Smith lo hubiera predicho.
Entonces, ¿qué nos deja eso?
Parece que las personas están motivadas por ciertos valores intrínsecos,
y en nuestra investigación, observamos esto.
Observamos la idea que las personas poseen los llamados valores protegidos.
Un valor protegido no es un valor cualquiera.
Un valor protegido es un valor donde está dispuesto a pagar un precio
para mantener ese valor.
Usted está dispuesto a pagar un precio para resistir a la tentación de ceder.
Y la consecuencia es que se siente mejor
si gana dinero de manera consistente con sus valores.
Déjeme mostrarle esto nuevamente, en la metáfora de nuestro querido perro.
Si conseguimos obtener la salchicha sin violar nuestros valores,
la salchicha tiene mejor sabor.
Eso es lo que muestra la investigación.
Si, en cambio,
lo hacemos...
obtenemos la salchicha
y al hacerlo violamos los valores,
valoramos menos la salchicha.
Cuantitativamente, eso es bastante poderoso.
Podemos medir esos valores protegidos,
por ejemplo,
a través de una encuesta.
Simple, encuesta de nueve puntos que es muy predecible en estos experimentos.
Si piensa en la generalidad de la población,
y luego hay una distribución a su alrededor...
las personas son diferentes, todos somos diferentes.
Personas que poseen una serie de valores protegidos
esa es una desviación estándar por encima de la media,
ellos descuentan el dinero que reciben mintiendo por cerca del 25 %.
Eso significa que un dólar recibido al estar mintiendo,
lo valoran en solo 75 centavos,
sin los incentivos que usted ofrece para que actúen honestamente.
Es su motivación intrínseca.
A propósito, no soy una autoridad moral.
No estoy diciendo que poseo esos magníficos valores, ¿correcto?
Aunque estoy interesado en cómo se comportan las personas,
y cómo podemos aprovechar esa riqueza en la naturaleza humana,
para así mejorar el funcionamiento de nuestras organizaciones.
De modo que hay dos visiones muy, muy diferentes aquí.
Por un lado,
se puede apelar a costos y beneficios
e intentar atraer personas a comportarse de manera acorde a ello.
Por otro lado,
puede seleccionar a las personas que poseen esos valores,
y las características deseables, por supuesto...
capacidades que van de acuerdo con su organización.
Aún no sé de dónde provienen estos valores protegidos,
¿es algo cultural o es natural?
Lo que sí puedo decir,
es que la distribución es muy similar entre hombres y mujeres.
Parece muy similar en aquellos que estudiaron economía,
o aquellos que estudiaron psicología.
También resulta muy similar en las diferentes categorías de edad
entre adultos.
Pero aún no sé cómo se desarrolla esto a lo largo de la vida.
Eso será sujeto de futura investigación.
El concepto que quiero dejar
es que está bien apelar a los incentivos.
Soy economista;
ciertamente creo que los incentivos funcionan.
Aunque, piensen en seleccionar a las personas correctas
más que en tener a las personas y luego presentar los incentivos.
Seleccionando las personas correctas, con los valores correctos,
pueden llegar muy lejos en ahorrar muchos problemas,
y mucho dinero,
en sus organizaciones.
En otras palabras,
redituará más el priorizar a las personas en primer lugar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)